in the last video we learned about what
is quite possibly the most profound idea
in statistics and that's the central
limit theorem and the reason why it's so
neat is we can start with any
distribution that has a well-defined
mean and variance actually I made this I
wrote the standard deviation in the last
video that should be the mean and let's
say it has some variance I could write
it like that or I could write the
standard deviation there but as long as
it has a well-defined mean and standard
deviation I don't care what the
distribution looks like what I can do is
take samples in the last video of save
size 4 so in that I take that means I
take literally 4 instances of this
random variable this is one example I
take their mean and I this I consider
this the sample mean for my first trial
or you could almost say for my first
sample I know it's very confusing
because you can consider that a sample
the set to be a sample or you could
consider each of its members of the each
member of the set as a sample so that
can be a little bit confusing there but
I have this first sample mean and then I
keep doing that over and over my in my
second sample my sample size is 4 I got
4 instances of this random variable I
averaged them I have another sample mean
and the cool thing about the central
limit theorem is as I keep plotting the
frequency distribution of my sample
means it starts to approach something
that approximates the normal
distribution and it's going to do a
better job of approximating that normal
distribution as n gets larger and just
so we have a little terminology on our
belt this frequency distribution right
here that I've plotted out and even or
here or up here that I started parting
plotting out that is called it's kind of
confusing because we use the word sample
so much that is called the sampling
sampling distribution distribution of
the sample mean and let's dissect this a
little bit just so that this long
description of this distribution starts
to make a little bit of sense when we
say it's the sampling distribution
that's telling us that it's being
derived from its the distribution of
some statistic which in this case
happens to be the sample mean and we're
deriving it from samples of an original
distribution so each of these
so this is my first sample my sample
size is four I'm using the statistic the
mean actually could have done with other
things I could have done the mode or the
or the range or other statistics the but
the sampling distribution of the sample
mean of the sample mean is the most
common one it's probably in my mind the
best place to start learning about the
central limit theorem and and even
frankly sampling distribution so that's
what it's called and this is a little
bit of background I'll prove this to you
experimentally not mathematically but I
think the experimental is on some levels
more satisfying with statistics that
this will have the same mean this will
have the same mean as your original
distribution as your original
distribution right here so it has the
same mean but we'll see in the next
video that this is actually going to be
it's going to start approximating a
normal distribution even though my
original distribution that this is kind
of generated from is completely non
normal so let's do that with this with
this app right here and just to give
proper credit where credit is due this
is I think was developed at Rice
University this is from online stat book
stat book.com this is their app and
which i think is a really neat app
because it really helps you to visualize
what a sampling distribution of the
sample mean is so I can literally create
my own custom distribution here so let
me make something kind of crazy so that
you could do this in theory with a with
a discrete or a continuous probability
density function but what they have here
is we can take on one of 32 values and
I'm just going to set the different
probabilities of getting any of those 32
values so clearly this right here is not
a normal distribution it looks a little
bit bimodal but it doesn't have long
tails but what I want to do is first
just use the simulation to understand or
to better understand what the sampling
distribution is all about so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take let's
start with five at a time so my sample
size is going to be five and so I when I
click animated what it's going to do is
going to take five samples from this
from this probability distribution
function it's going to take five samples
and you're gonna see them when I click
animate it it's going to average them
and plot the average down here and then
I'm going to click it again it's going
to do it again so there you go I've got
five samples from there
average them and it hit there what did I
just do
I clicked oh I wanted to clear that let
me let me make this bottom one none so
let me do that it over again so I'm
gonna take five at a time
so I took five samples from up here and
then it took its mean and plotted the
mean there let me do it again
five samples from this probability
distribution function plotted it right
there I could keep doing it it'll take
some time but you can see I plotted it
right there now I could do this a
thousand times it's going to take
forever let's say I just wanted to do it
a thousand times so it's this program
just to be clear it's actually
generating the random numbers this isn't
like a rigged program it's actually
going to generate the random numbers
according to this probability
distribution function it's going to take
five at a time find their means and plot
the mean so if I click 10,000 it's going
to do that ten thousand times so it's
going to take five numbers from here
10,000 times and find their means 10,000
times and then plot the 10,000 means
here so let's do that
so there you go notice it's already
looking a lot like a normal distribution
and like I said the original mean of my
crazy distribution here was fourteen
point four five and the mean of after
doing 10,000 samples or 10,000 trials my
mean here's fourteen point four two so
I'm already getting pretty close to the
mean they're my standard deviation you
might notice it's less than that we'll
talk about that in a future video
and the skew and kurtosis these are idea
these these are are things that help us
measure how normal a distribution is and
I've talked a little bit about it in the
past and let me let me actually just
diverge a little bit and and just so
it's interesting and they're fairly
straightforward concepts skew literally
tells so if this is let me do it in a
different color if this is a Norfolk
normal distribution and clearly my
drawing is very far from perfect if
that's a perfect distribution if this
would have a skew of zero if you have a
positive skew that means you have a
larger right tail than you would have
otherwise expect so something with a
positive skew might look like this it
would have a large tail to the right so
this would be a positive skew positive
skew which makes it a little less than
ideal for a normal distribution and a
negative skew would look like this has a
long tail to the left
so negative skew might look like that so
that is a negative skew if you have
trouble remembering it just remember
which direction the tail is going this
tail is going through is the negative
direction this tail is going to the
positive direction so if something has
no skew that means that it's nice and
symmetrical around its mean now kurtosis
which sounds like a very fancy word is
similarly not that not that fancy of an
idea kurtosis so once again if I were to
draw a perfect normal distribution
remember you know there's no one normal
distribution you could have different
means and different standard deviations
let's say that's the perfect normal
distribution if I have positive kurtosis
if I have positive rotation kurtosis
what's going to happen is I'm going to
have fatter tails let me draw it a
little nicer than that I'm going to have
fatter tails but I'm going to have a
more pointy peak I didn't you have to
draw at that point to let me draw it
like this I'm going to have fatter tails
and I'm going to have a more pointy peak
than a normal distribution so this right
here is positive kurtosis so something
that has positive kurtosis isn't it's
you know it depending on how positive it
is it tells you it's a little bit more
pointy than a real normal distribution
positive kurtosis and negative kurtosis
has smaller tails but it's smoother near
the middle so it's like this so
something like this would have negative
kurtosis negative kurtosis and maybe in
future videos we'll explore that in more
detail but in the context of this
simulation it's just telling us how
normal this distribution is so when our
sample size was n equal five and we did
10,000 trials we got it pretty close to
a normal distribution let's do another
10,000 trials just to see what happens
it looks even more like a normal
distribution our mean is now the exact
same number but we still have a little
bit of skew and a little bit of kurtosis
now let's see what happens if we were to
do the same thing with a larger sample
size and we can actually do them
simultaneously so here is n equal 5
let's do here N equals 25 let's go let
me clear them I'm going to do the sample
sampling distribution of the sample mean
and so I'm going to run 10,000 trial so
I'll do 1 animated trial just so you
remember what's going on so I'm
literally taking first 5 samples from
over here find their mean now I'm taking
25 samples from up here find its mean
and then plotting it down here so here
the sample size is 25 here it's 5 I'll
do it one more time I take 5 get the
mean plot it take 25 get the mean and
then plot it down there this is a larger
sample size now that that thing that I
just did I'm going to do 10,000 times
10,000 times and that's interesting
remember our first distribution was just
this really crazy very non normal
distribution but once we did it whoops I
didn't want to make it that big
but once we scroll up a little bit so
here what's interesting I mean they both
look a little normal but if you look at
the skew and the kurtosis when our
sample size is larger it's more normal
this has a lower skew then when our
sample size was only 5 and it has a less
negative kurtosis then when our sample
size was 5 so this is this is a more
normal distribution and one thing that
we're going to explore further in a
future video is not only is it more
normal in its shape but it's also
tighter fit around the mean and you can
even think about it why that kind of
makes sense when your sample size is
larger your odds of getting really far
away from the mean is lower because it's
very low likelihood if you're taking 25
samples or 100 samples that you're going
to get a bunch of stuff way out here a
bunch of stuff way out here you're very
likely to get a reasonable spread of
things so it makes sense that your mean
your sample mean is less likely to be
far away from the mean we're going to
talk a little bit more about that in the
future but hopefully this kind of
satisfies you that at least
experimentally I haven't proven it to
you with mathematical rigor which
hopefully we'll do in the future but
hopefully this satisfies you at least
experimentally that the central limit
theorem really does apply to any
distribution I mean this is a crazy
distribution I encourage you to to use
this applet that online stat book comm
and experiment with other crazy
distributions to believe it for yourself
but the interesting things there are is
that we're approaching a normal
distribution but as my sample size got
larger it's a better fit for a normal
distribution